it's been 20 years since the beginning
of halo a series that would change the
way we look at console shooters forever
and still being able to play them all to
this day makes it even easier to revisit
our favorites a lot has evolved over the
past two decades for the franchise and
with halo infinite right around the
corner we thought it would be a great
time to take a look at the evolution of
some of our favorite halo weapons
starting with the magnum leave a like
subscribe and let's get to it
in my opinion while the magnum in combat
evolved is the greatest one on the list
today it's almost so good that it left
shoes simply too big to fill so we'll
consider it in a league of its own the
ce magnum is an absolute powerhouse it
takes only three shots to kill from just
about any range and being able to scope
in makes it that much easier to mow down
your enemies in theory with a clip size
of 12 you could wipe a whole squad
without even having to reload if the
star is aligned this was also long
before bloom was something the devs had
to consider for pistols making it even
more dangerous as if all of that wasn't
good enough it can be easy to forget
that we also start with all of the ammo
we could possibly need with 60 bullets
on hand every single time you spawn
needless to say this magnum is one of
the best guns in the series and can make
talking about the next ones a little bit
painful
[Music]
halo 2 is my personal favorite halo and
the one i think the most hours into but
i don't think much of that time was
spent using pistols and it's pretty
obvious why with the addition of dual
welding the power of the magnum was
drastically reduced the fire rate for
the pistol is faster than what it was in
ce but it takes a massive number of 13
shots to get the kill if that sounds
like a lot well it is because the clip
size is still only 12 bullets and you
only spawn with 36 bullets in the pocket
this time around dual wielding with an
energy weapon makes the pistol much more
viable but in the bigger picture of halo
2 we were often opting for a shiny new
battle rifle instead as things like the
double shot became second nature for
some players the pistol served its
purpose by simply being the secondary
weapon to allow a flurry of non-stop vr
bullets and preventing your gun from
jamming to add insult to injury the
scope was also removed from magnum
making it even more difficult to use in
a pinch
halo 3's magnum got a few buffs in
comparison to halo 2 although the bar
was admittedly very low it now takes 5
shots to kill but the fire rate is
slower than the halo 2 magnum and the
clip size is reduced to 8. this makes
the magnum better in finishing off weak
opponents if you could overcome the slow
weapon swapping but still not the type
of weapon you would use as a primary
especially since our spawning ammo
capacity is once again reduced this time
being 32 rounds although this version of
the magnum is a major improvement from
two there is still no ability to scope
which is likely a byproduct of dual
building as halo 2 and 3 were the only
games to allow dual welding with magnums
and also the only two to remove the
scopes from the gun however the accuracy
of the magnum without a scope at a
distance is still surprisingly
consistent ultimately the magnum in pvp
was still in a place where it was being
passed up in favor of the more popular
and practical
rifles when it comes to halo reach it
might be one of my least favorite of the
series in pvp because i personally
wasn't prepared for all of the new
abilities but with that aside this
version of the magnum marked the road to
recovery it's the first magnum since
combat evolved to bring back the scope
and also the first one in the series to
add bloom the fire rate has been bumped
up and we're returning with a 5 shot
kill in an 8 round clip just like halo
3. however this time we're starting with
an abysmal 24 shots of magnum ammo
adding quite a sense of urgency to
scavenging scopeless magnums from halo 2
and 3 were already a thing of the past
at this point but the accuracy of the
reach version of the gun was much less
consistent at a distance even with the
scope taking into consideration that
halo reach also had a lot of new
elements for players to adapt to such as
better long range marksman rifles armor
lock and other abilities it's easy to
overlook the magnum and its improvements
however this magnum can go toe-to-toe
with the other rifles in the game and at
least you still feel capable of putting
down team shots from long range instead
of watching helplessly from a distance
and hoping your hail mary grenade
doesn't friendly fire
halo 4's magnum is almost a pleasant
surprise it takes six quick shots to
kill and the fire rate has remained
somewhat consistent with its previous
version in reach halo 4's magnum is
definitely viable but i often find
myself running out of ammo right in the
middle of a fight the clip size is the
same as halo 3 and reach with 8 shots at
your disposal but we're once again
spawning with 24 rounds in total which
makes it absolutely crucial to scavenge
ammo from your enemies but that's
uniquely difficult in halo 4 since
players can choose their own loadout
this means there isn't as much of a
guarantee to run into magnum ammo when
you get a kill ultimately another big
big big big downfall for the magnum in
halo 4 was the removal of the d scope
mechanic making it even more difficult
to take on other rifles especially at a
range
halo 5 is one of my favorite games in
the series and the magnum made a big
return as a viable primary weapon and a
deadly threat it takes five shots to
kill and this time around we're blessed
with a 12 round clip our starting ammo
capacity is up to 36 but with its
viability finding ammo off of your
enemies is much more common the scope
and bloom return but the bloom doesn't
impact the magnum's accuracy at a range
nearly as much as it did in halo reach
the d-scope making a return also makes a
big difference in taking on fights
against other rifles and adds even more
practicality to the gun with the
additional core movement options such as
the thrusts you can now outmaneuver your
opponents in different ways that make
the magnum even more satisfactory when
you get those clean reversals
we're tossing the halo infinite magnum
on this list after getting our hands on
the technical preview but it's worth
noting that the build we played on was a
few months old and not exactly what
we'll be seeing at launch however the
magnum in infinite so far is looking
like a formidable weapon the fire rate
fills close to that of the halo 2 magnum
and takes seven quick shots to kill that
sounds like a lot considering it's the
second most bullets needed behind halo 2
but there's something about the fire
rate and the snappy reload time that
makes it feel lightning fast it
currently sits with a 12 round clip size
and a starting ammo capacity of 48 which
is the second most since ce the bloom on
infinite's gun is actually what makes
the biggest difference up close a rapid
fire seven shot perfect kill feels
nearly impossible to miss so the bloom
doesn't get in the way too much but
apply that same strategy at a range and
you're shooting blanks there will be a
bit of mastery with this iteration but
definitely one of the strongest versions
so far even up against other rifles as
the scope returns and the d scope
mechanic is in full effect
we've seen the magnum in so many ways
shapes and forms but which magnum in the
series is your favorite let us know in
the comments and if you enjoyed this
video then be sure you subscribe for
more we'll be covering all things halo
here on gamespot so stay with us to stay
up to date thanks for watching and we'll
see you next time peace
[Music]
you
[Music]